er hat den vereinigten europa die macht
in der hand
angela merkel werden viele sagen ich
habe werde ihnen gleich im studio einen
wand vorstellen da in nicht wenigen
europäischen schicksalsfragen weit mehr
zu sagen hatte in den letzten zwölf
jahren als merkel und co das empfehlen
in der öffentlichkeit nicht bekannt ist
und aus griechenland kommt macht die
sache nur noch spannender und hängt
damit zusammen dass er diskret gewirkt
hat von dem justizpalast 1000 luxemburg
in dem europas höchstes gericht tat
dieses hat er als gerichtspräsident
entscheidungsfreudig oder sagen andere
mit straffer hand geführt bis er vor
wenigen tagen zurücktrat herzlich
willkommen vassilios skouris wir freuen
uns wirklich sehr dass sie für er erst
das großes fernsehgespräch nach ablauf
der rechtlichen zurückhaltung pflicht
unsere einladung in die sternstunde
angenommen haben
oh ja ihren wusste eigentlich die
bäckersfrau wo sie ihre brötchen holten
oder der kellner in ihrem lieblingslokal
was für ein wichtiger mann in europa sie
war
ich nehme an in vielen fällen ist das
der fall gewesen aber das hat den mimen
mir gegenüber in keiner weise verändert
weil luxemburg ist ja wie sie wissen ein
kleines land ein sehr friedliches land
ein ruhiges land und da sind sehr viele
leute tätig lauter wichtige neuerung in
diesem sinne wichtig nicht der
mächtigste richter europas war ja gut
dann ist der kellner gekommen und hat
gesagt ja ich hab ein problem
glücklicherweise ist es so dass der
gerichtshof dann eben nicht über
einzelne individuelle fälle entscheidet
sondern dies nur tut wenn die nationalen
gerichte der nationale richter sich an
den europäischen gerichtshof wendet aber
inhalte sind die kataloge manchmal ist
es sicherlich wie das sicherlich richtig
aber eben nicht in dem sinne dass man
eine direkte klage ja ja sie haben das
letzte woche von dem betreiber immerhin
schoss manuel barroso sagte in dieser
sendungen anfangen ja wenige tage
nachdem er aus seinem amt verabschiedet
worden war
mit augenzwinkern sagt ja man spüre den
machtverlust wenn man hinten in sein
großes auto steigt und der wagen nicht
anspringt hatten sich als ein richtiger
präsident einen chauffeur
ja ich hatte ihn schon vorher jetzt ein
dienstwagen diese insignien der macht
sind weg ist das komisch vaters komisch
am 17 oktober das letzte mal die bürotür
zu ziehen ich war der wichtigste richter
europas und jetzt bin ich ein
normalbürger
das würde ich nicht sagen also man muss
sich auch auf diese zeit vorbereiten und
ich habe immer das motto gerd man muss
mit den dingen leben können aber man
muss sich auch daran gewöhnen ohne die
dinge zu leben und wenn man sich gut
vorbereitet und auch vielleicht das ist
auch sehr wichtig den eindruck hat dass
man seine arbeit gut getan hat dann
würde ich sagen ist der abgang nicht so
schwierig kein bisschen machtverlust
kater nein noch nicht
jedenfalls ich habe nicht die zeit
gehabt darüber nachzudenken
natürlich sie sind immer noch gefragt
von universität zu universität will man
wissen was der höchste jurist europa so
denkt jetzt was uns vielleicht erstaunen
kann ist dass just ein mann aus
griechenland auf dem olymp der
europäischen justiz zum schluss die
oberste die jupiter position innehat wie
ist das ein starkes jahr in griechische
berg ja es ist logisch wir brauchen
europa wurde ja von ihnen erfunden den
griechen also hat schon seine logik aber
wenn es trotzdem
entstanden war das ein früher traum
wollten sie nie fußballprofi werden oder
pilot sondern immer höchste richter nein
das sicherlich nicht ich bin in einer
juristin familie aufgewachsen und daher
traditions- mäßig daneben auch jurist
geworden
ich habe also dann im ausland studiert
in deutschland ich war dann abgewählt
die akademische laufbahn
aber juristen familie alle sind juristen
außer ihre gattin aber haben sich die
kinder sind juristen die eltern viele
normalbürger finden die jurisprudenz ein
bisschen langweilig bei ihnen war das
war dass das thema am frühstückstisch
das nicht dass nicht aber wissen sie man
kommt ja zur juristerei
wenn man aus einer humanistischen
bildung heraus dann überlegt ganz
einfach was will ich machen wenn mich
eben die humanistische humanistischen
studien interessieren
und der jurist oder die juristerei
eröffnet ja eine breite palette von
möglichkeiten und deswegen nehme ich an
werden sehr viele leute zu juristen das
ist ja dann eben nicht vorgegeben
sondern das ist eine sachliche
entscheidung die man trifft und
sicherlich spielte auch eine rolle und
hat bei mir auch gespielt die tradition
in der familie in dem sinne dass man
daneben gewissermaßen in der lokalen
gesellschaft zumindest bekannt ist nicht
also wenn man schon in einer solchen
tradition schon dass ich einen anderen
weg gewählt habe
das ist dann eben eine frage des zufalls
nicht das ist nicht vorgegeben und man
kann auch nicht darauf hinarbeiten
richter geschweige denn präsident beim
europäischen gerichtshof zu werden viel
glück dabei auch nicht das ist
schicksalsgöttin wissen gehört im spielt
eine rolle und stoßen
ja schon sie sind aber ein waschechter
grieche und reden deutsch dass man den
griechen kaum mehr heraus hört was hat
sie an der deutschen kultur so
fasziniert sie ging dann nach berlin
zunächst einmal war ich auf einer
deutschen schule
griechenland in thessaloniki und ich hab
dann ein stipendium bekommen warum war
das ein bisschen elite familie die
ältere aber auch eine sehr gute schule
ja das war eine sehr gute schule und das
war sicherlich die überlegung meine
eltern dass ich dann hier eine gute
schule gehe
aber dann kam eben das eine zum anderen
also ich bekam ein stipendium und
deswegen habe ich ein studium begonnen
in eine großstadt in berlin nicht die
dann berlin hatte ich ein jahr vorher
besucht vor dem beginn meines studiums
und ich habe die stadt sehr interessant
gefunden die geteilte stadt damals war
noch der kalte krieg da aber offenbar
gut nach ost berlin gehen ja das konnte
man als ausländer hatte man die
möglichkeit zu gehen natürlich unter
strenger überwachung und kontrolle aber
die möglichkeit bestand und das war also
eine sehr schöne und interessante zeit
in berlin mit einem sehr guten studium
und dagegen von den aus berlin auch das
recht stück die ansagen sind ein
humanistischer müssen aber sehr viel ja
wir haben unser wissen vorbereitet und
gern sie sehen sich dann paragrafen
fressen sie sind dass das könnte man
auch nicht das dürfte man nicht sagen
man muss natürlich auch sehr genau
verstehen man muss guter jurist sein
man muss auch sehr genau verstehen was
die nöte der menschen sind ist und wie
wie das umfeld ist in dem man lebt und
da spielen natürlich diese dinge auch
eine ganz wichtige rolle wie gesagt zum
schluss brachte die schicksalsgöttin sie
voll auf den olymp in luxemburg höchstes
europäisches gericht was müssen wir uns
darunter vorstellen da sind jetzt 28
hohe richter aus verschiedenen kulturen
verschiedenen ländern die suchen
gemeinsam nach der wahrheit
nur schon in welcher sprache machen die
das unser arbeitssprache ist französisch
ist französisch geblieben es war ja von
anfang an als der gerichtshof
beziehungsweise die europäische
gemeinschaft die europäischen
gemeinschaften aus 6
gründungsstaaten bestanden war die
arbeitssprache französisch und die
arbeitssprache ist französisch geblieben
aber den gerichtshof ist hier ein multi
linguistisches system oder hat ein multi
linguistische system das heißt beim
gerichtshof werden alle sprachen benutzt
alle amtssprachen wir haben wir haben
dann 23 amtssprachen und man darf
natürlich seinen fall bzw
der richter seine entscheidung in der er
uns um rat fragt in seiner eigenen
sprache
das braucht ein heer von übersetzungen
das ist richtig werden also ungefähr 800
800 juristen juristen im
übersetzungsdienste das ist der größte
dienst des gerichtshofes der gerichtshof
hat ungefähr ein personal von 2200
menschen den auch dabei haben sie
ziemlich ausgebaute ja aber gut das kam
so wolle von der sache her ja das ist
also keine entscheidung des präsidenten
gewesen
man braucht eben auch sagen viele leute
um dann eben dieses system der funktion
funktionell zu halt und funktionierte es
meistens ich habe von einem lustigen
fall gelesen wo ein fall auf finnisch
behandelt wurde und dann war ein
unmögliches weniger source bi oder daten
so und das wurde falsch übersetzt und
dann eine zeit lang haben dann dann
haben sie das sehr genau untersucht er
klappt es ist richtig dass dann es so
funktioniert hat das ist also eine ich
meine die unsere entscheidungen werden
in allen amtssprachen übersetzt
das heißt es gibt also am tag der
verkündung des urteils das urteil in
allen amtssprachen genauso wie die
schlussanträge unsere generalanwälte die
dann dem gerichtshof einen vorschlag
unterbreiten in den wichtigen fällen
auch in allen amtssprachen übersetzt
wird
aber natürlich ist die eigentlich
ansprache in jedem urteil
mache dies die die verfahren sprache
nicht das wird bestimmt durch den
antragsteller beziehungsweise durch das
gericht dass die frage stellt in diesem
fall war es eben finish und eine
kollegin also die frühere präsidentin
des bundesverwaltungsgerichts hatte mir
geschrieben um zu sagen dass da ein wort
wahrscheinlich wie ein kollege von ihr
in einem sehr technischen umweltschutz
fall entdeckt wurde nicht richtig
benutzt und übersetzt worden ist was wir
dann nach geprüft haben und es besteht
die möglichkeit dass dann auch richtig
zu stellen das war dann gerade das
gegenteil es dürfte keine ausnahmen
geben
auf jeden fall offenbar aber sehr oft
entsteht war in der deutschen fassung
beim japanischen fassung war es riecht
und die gilt dann ja gilt natürlich also
das ist dies die entscheidende aber auch
da kann man nachträglich mal ein fehler
entdecken
das kann ein tippfehler gewesen sei
nicht dann einem entgangen ist und das
muss man dann korrigieren aber das sind
keine dramatischen fälle ok mit ihren
hunderten juristische ausgebildeten
übersetzern
da findet man meistens die richtige
lösung kameras ist um der kultur her da
kommen die 28 richter aus so
verschiedenen ländern und man sucht
gemeinsam die wahrheit findet man die
gewinnt einfach wie habermas gesagt
hätte die kraft des besseren arguments
sicherlich spielt das bessere argument
eine ganz entscheidende rolle und ich
darf vielleicht sagen ohne also nun das
beratungsgeheimnis zu verraten dass
unsere entscheidungen sehr konsensual
sind also sie werden genau überprüft
genau bearbeitet und es ist ganz wichtig
zu betonen dass bei seinen
entscheidungen die beratung die
entscheidende rolle spielt also die
beratung ist eine echte kollegiale
beratung eine herausforderung für die
teilnehmenden richtern richter
und man kommt also doch dann zu einem
ergebnis das wenn nicht immer von allen
geteilt wird dann doch von einer sehr
überzeugenden mehrheit
viele haben aber gesagt und geschrieben
obwohl es ein kollegiales gremium ist
waren sie der wettermacher eigentlich
weit nur schon
sie haben als gerichtspräsident die
macht die fälle zuzuteilen das ist
richtig dass auch ziemlich steuern ja
und nein zunächst einmal wird man ja als
präsident immer von seinen kollegen
gewählt
und da ich das glück und die ehre hatte
von meinen kollegen wiederholt gewählt
zu werden muss ich dann wahrscheinlich
bei der verteilung ein richtigen weg
gefunden haben dass die kollegin auch
damit zufrieden waren und nicht den
eindruck hatte nicht würde also durch
die verteilung der fälle die sache eben
steuern das scheint ein bisschen ihre
lebensphilosophie zu sein nicht als
dampfwalze auch wenn man die macht hat
er alles platt zu walzen dadurch zu
fahren durch die landschaft sondern
dauernd verhandeln
man muss überzeugen es ist wichtig zu
überzeugen und es ist wichtig auch den
kollegen die möglichkeit zu geben dass
sie ihre überzeugung vortragen und dass
man dann eben auf der grundlage der
überlegungen angestellt worden sind das
ist vielleicht das amt und die kunst des
präsidenten dann eben die debatte auf
die wichtigen fragen zu konzentrieren
und dann zu einem ergebnis zu kommen
was ist ihr ideal zur gerechtigkeit
begriff wonach hat man gesucht nach der
wahrheit oder nach einem möglichst guten
kompromiss
man hat gesucht nach der richtigen
auslegung und anwendung des rechts ich
meine
für den richter wissen sie der ist in
einer bequemeren position wenn das recht
dass er anwendet relativ klar ist dann
hatte glaube dann hat er von sich aus
nicht so viel beizutragen er muss
subsumieren und das ergebnis das könnte
ja auch ein computer machen dann das
könnte ja bis zu einem jahr
es gibt einen großen fortschritt bei den
computern bzw bei den robotern das kann
man glaube ich im moment nicht genau
diskutieren aber es trifft auch zu das
muss man sagen ganz offen sagen dass
gesetze wie das dann auch in den
mitgliedstaaten und in den staaten der
fall ist das ergebnis von kompromissen
sind und kompromisse sind nicht dadurch
ausgezeichnet immer dass sie klar sind
sondern dass sie daneben dem bericht der
die aufgabe übertragen und manchmal wird
das auch klar gesagt nicht also wir
können das nicht besser machen dass wir
der richter schon entscheiden oder der
richter wird das riecht ja und da waren
ein paar doch so ganz wie das ist
sicherlich da haben sie völlig recht die
fälle gibt es auch und da muss man eben
sehen nach welchen kriterien man zu
einem ergebnis kommt beim gericht sofort
beim europäischen recht spielt das
sogenannte nützliche ergebnisse wie man
das dann eben als erstes aber wer
entscheidungen was nützliches und neben
da die mehrheit erreicht die mehrheit
entscheidet was da nicht was ist der
effekt dieser regelung die vielleicht
zunächst einmal nicht besonders klar
wird wirkt und es kommt eben dazu dass
wir dann eben versuchen diesen effekten
zu finden und ich hoffe dass es uns
gelingt in den meisten fällen auch zu
finden
also das war eine kollegiale sache sie
haben mich überzeugt aber trotzdem
investiere ich nur noch ein kleines
bisschen
man sagt sie waren der strenge
steuermann sie konnten also hohen
regierungsvertretern die chefjuristen
die mehrere europäische regierung
vertrauten ziemlich übers maul fahren
gab gab ein anwalt materie oder so dem
haben sie gesagt kommt zur sache und so
sie waren ein ziemlich strenge richter
wissen sie es geht dann um die mündliche
verhandlung und die mündliche
verhandlung hat natürlich auch den sinn
nicht den parteien zu gestatten dass sie
noch einmal wiederholen was sie bereits
schriftlich vorgelegt haben und sondern
dem gerichtshof nützlich zu sein
das heißt wir wollen von den parteien
gewisse fragen geklärt haben die uns
wichtig erscheinen und ich habe immer
versucht dies dann deutlich zu machen
dass es darum geht dem gerichtshof zu
dienen und nicht also der
selbstdarstellung und da kann es
manchmal vorgekommen sein dass ich
vielleicht etwas streng reagiert habe
damit aber damit uns die möglichkeit
bleibt denn eine mündliche verhandlung
gerade vor der großen kammer jetzt 15
richter und einem generalanwalt ist ja
auch keine leichte sache also man muss
schon sich konzentrieren und das kann
auch nicht acht stunden dauern nicht
denn das weit man weiß das hilft nicht
der konzentration also man muss die
erste teil muss sie ja kurz sein
wichtig ist der teil der fragen die wir
stellen sie waren sicher da nahtlos aus
prinzip sondern weil es der sache dient
der also machen sie vorwärts an davon so
ist es sagt man tatsächlich kommen sie
zur sache haben sie dem was mal gefallen
ja ich weiß nicht was in dem fall ein
französisch auf ein französischer fall
war oder kein französischer fall er sein
zuhause habe ich gelesen aber das meer
die naumann gerechnet positiv dass sie
die sache in der hand hatten jetzt
wollen wir schauen was dieses gericht
inhaltlich alles so entschied
hat spannende dinge ich habe mir ja
sowieso gesagt von der schweizer aus ihr
überlegen wir uns oft was ist das für
ein europa die hand sind fasziniert
sagen europa das ist das neue mutterland
der wert der menschenrechte
wo man mehr als in amerika usa die
rechte des bürgers schützt weniger
geheimdienste und überwachung hat und so
andere sagen ein europa ist ein moloch
ein bürokratisches monster das alles
regeln wir die krankheit der planung die
länge der gurken und ich habe mir gesagt
sie sind eigentlich das wandelnde
europäische ideal an ihn kann man sehen
es gibt den europäischen bürger der aus
dem süden kommt im norden erfolg gehabt
viel weiß gescheit ist sympathisch ist
und noch höchster richter wird also sind
jetzt ein bisschen mein testobjekt um zu
auszuloten ob europa mehr der moloch ist
oder das mutterland der rechte und der
werte und wenn wir jetzt die letzten
fälle anschauen nehme ich mal an würden
sie darauf plädieren
da hat das höchste europäische gericht
jetzt viel gemacht um die rechte des
bürgers zu schützen das war ein bisschen
ihre handschrift auch dass er gab sich
also aus der aus dem aus der tatsache
dass die fälle an uns gekommen sind
wissen sie
ein gericht kann ja nicht von sich aus
von amts wegen tätig werden ein gericht
ist so gut und so nützlich wie es die
fälle erlauben
und es trifft zu dass wir in der letzten
zeit daneben eine reihe von fällen
gehabt haben die sich dadurch daraus
ergeben haben dass jetzt nach dem
vertrag von lissabon die europäische
union mehr zuständigkeiten bekommen hat
und auf dem berühmten raum der freiheit
der sicherheit und des rechts daneben
tätig geworden ist durch eine reihe von
maßnahmen und initiativen und diese
initiativen haben dann eben diese fälle
gegeben
natürlich verbunden mit dem auch
formalen inkrafttreten der grundrechte
charta
europa verfügt über eine
grundrechte-charta aus 53 artikeln
die dann eben wenn man das dann global
seed die dann eben die grundrechte die
modernste grundrechte der modernste
grundrechtskatalog auf der welt ist
und der vielleicht schönste fall der
belegt wie jetzt dieses gericht mächtig
seine stimme donnern ließ der hat
stattgefunden am zweitletzten arbeitstag
in ihrer schönen karriere am 6 oktober
um siebter haben sie als büro ghana
abgeschlossen
und dort hat man gesehen dass der
europäische gerichtshof nicht bloß
komplexe abstrakte juristische
fachfragen beurteilt sondern eben auch
dinge die sehr direkt ins leben der eu
bürger eingreifen
das war das urteil ein junger
österreicher ein student max schrems jus
student hat facebook verklagt weil er
gesagt hat die geben seine daten dort in
amerika in usa trieben dem geheimdienst
nsa und so das passte nicht hat sich
heraf geklagt durch alle gerichte und an
ihrem vorletzten arbeitstag euer ehren
liegt die sache zur entscheidung in
luxemburg eine unserer wichtigen
nachrichtensendung 10 vor 10 hat das als
aufmacher am abend des 6 oktober
gebracht und das drängt denn an so jahre
lang hat er mit facebook gestritten
heute war sein tag des triumphes der 27
jährige jus student max schrems
die richter entschieden dass seine daten
in den usa zu wenig gut vor dem zugriff
von geheimdiensten und behörden
geschützt sind
das urteil gilt als wegweisend aber
nutzt ein user facebook in europa werden
seine daten auf facebook servern in den
usa gespeichert
denn facebook ist amerikanisch in den
usa allerdings ist der datenschutz lasch
er fand heute der europäische
gerichtshof im hinterkopf hatte er den
nsa spionage skandal
bisher konnten amerikanische firmen ein
zertifikat einholen genannte safe harbor
damit bestätigten sie dass sie die daten
aus europa gemäß den strengen
europäischen datenschutzbestimmungen
behandeln
das gericht hat nun aber entschieden
dass dieser zertifikate keinen
ausreichenden schutz garantieren und
damit nichtig sind
ja er ist christ frühjahr hat das
gericht milchquoten und zement
konglomerat die und so beurteilt und
jetzt das wo man abwägen muss zwischen
der freiheit des individuums unter
sicherheit man die amerikaner blöd sind
sie auch nicht die machen ja auch eine
abwägung sagen schutz vor terror braucht
eben möglichkeiten für die geheimdienste
das nicht die bösen kräfte siegen zum
schluss schläft man da manchmal als
rechter schlecht und hinter sind sich
auch wie viel freiheit soll ich dem
individuum geben wie viel schutz ich
glaube heute glücklicherweise müssen wir
also nun diese abwägung auf der
grundlage von bestimmten und konkreten
normen machen und in diesem fall wie in
den vorausgegangenen fall digital rights
ging es darum war das google damals das
war nicht googeln das war die fordert
teil juli haben sie auch noch nie
gesehen sagte sport auf vergessen ich
meine man muss diese drei urteile
eigentlich zusammen nehmen also dieser
reiz und damals uns aidlingen das war
auch ein österreichischer fall ein
irischer und österreichischen fall
das war 2014 dann google spain und jetzt
scheint es da gibt es in der
grundrechte-charta den artikel 7 und den
artikel 8 die schützen die daten die
persönlichen daten der bürger und zwar
auch gegenüber privaten also das ist ein
schutz der das hat was man in der
juristerei unmittelbare tritt wirkung
das heißt dieser schutz gilt auch
gegenüber privaten das ist natürlich für
googles bin ganz wichtig weil google ja
nicht der staat in dem gegenüber das
grundrecht geltend gemacht wird
also das ist der eine punkt und dieser
schutz geht dann sehr weit auf grund der
grundrechte-charta also kann konnte der
gerichtshof nichts anderes sagen als bei
dieser reiz dass die anlasslose
speicherung auf unbegrenzte zeit fast
von daten von bürgern ohne dass es dann
die finanzierungen gibt dass die nicht
vereinbar ist mit dem datenschutz der
dann durch die grundrechte-charta
garantiert ist und das gleiche gilt bei
schrempps für diese entscheidung die
dann die kommission auf der grundlage
einer richtlinie getroffen hat das dann
eben auf amerikanischer seite der schutz
ein ebenbürtiger oder eine adäquate
rechtsschutz und rechtsschutz gewährt
wird wie der die das sei in europa der
fall ist das haben wir festgestellt war
nicht der fall
und da ergibt sich für den richter keine
schwierige aufgabe als zu sagen sagte
der computer wieder gleich nein das ist
sicherlich nicht sowieso nicht
es kommt darauf an wie hoch man diesen
wertansätze hatten dieser wert ist dann
eben sehr hoch in europa und dies wollte
der gerichtshof auch zeigen dass es zu
verteidigen gilt damit sind sie weltweit
kann man sagen zu den vorkämpfern
geworden für eine entschieden
individuelle auslegung dieser dieser
rechte des bürgers und da das kann nur
individuell
ja meine daten werden geschätzt er nicht
das ist eben das individuum oder andere
das nachsehen seine privatheit und das
ist natürlich ein ganz wichtiger
gesichtspunkt sie wissen daher ist heute
sicherlich nicht sehr schwer ist auf der
grundlage auch von bestimmten daten also
profile zu erstellen also das ist doch
jedem bekannt auch denjenigen die
technisch vielleicht nicht sehr
bewandert sind wie sie also insofern
kann man sagen ist die gefahr doch groß
und das risiko ist daneben wieso man
sagen das ist eben ein sehr hohes risiko
und das
konnte man nicht akzeptieren diese
gefahr ist da man sieht sie weltweit und
ich stelle mir vor sie wurden auch zu
recht würde man sagen gefeiert als
vorkämpfer für den erhalt der
privatsphäre in der güterabwägung an für
sich sind ja die institutionen der eu
nicht sehr populär und beliebt augen
fragen auf die hälfte der eu bevölkerung
findet das nicht gut was sie in brüssel
machen und in luxemburg
und so hat dass die popularität jetzt
gesteigert dass man hier als
menschenrechts maschine daherkommt das
war jedenfalls nicht unser ziel also
dass die popularität gesteigert wird
sondern unsere ziel war richtiges recht
zu sprechen
ja es ist recht zu dass dann europa sehr
oft und sehr stark als eine
bürokratische mechanismus beschrieben
wird daran ist vielleicht die politik
nicht ganz unschuld weil sie dann doch
dieses diesen eindruck diesem eindruck
nicht den ski entschieden auf
staatsebene auf mitglied als ebenen
entgegentritt
aber ist es nicht auch ein bisschen ein
berechtigter eindruck ist es nicht ein
bisschen ein monster mit abertausenden
verordnungen und eben das berühmte
korpus der liegt ist dann die gurke die
gekrümmt sein muss
darüber kann man ja immer streiten und
es ist richtig dass man auch recht
entschlacken kann dass das gibt dann
gibt es überhaupt keinen zweifel
aber es wäre glaube ich ungerecht jetzt
europa gleich zu setzen mit diesen etwas
über über betonten bei spielen
europa ist für mich und das war es immer
eine wertegemeinschaft eine rechts und
eine wertegemeinschaft man muss sehen
dass in diesem vereinten europa von
anfang an institutionen gewirkt haben
die dem recht verpflichtet waren
das ist also keine normale
internationale organisation sondern das
ist eine organisation die von anfang an
als rechtsgemeinschaft gebildet wurde
und natürlich da auch mit einem
gerichtshof drüber weitgehende
kompetenzen verfügt und über kompetenzen
gerade auch
gegenüber den mitgliedstaaten das heißt
die kommission kann einen mitgliedsstaat
verklagen gegenüber aero vor seien
luxemburg weil dieser mitgliedstaat also
die seine verpflichtungen aus dem
unionsrecht nicht erfüllt hat nicht
eingehalten hat also das ist natürlich
auf internationaler ebene wie sie wissen
ein großer fortschritt da braucht man
keine verhandlungen zu führen sondern
das ist dann eben vertrag so und dann
aber steht ist gibt halt auch kreise die
das sehr kritisch sehen und sagen dass
die tatsache dass diese kompetenzen
immer weiter nach oben gegangen sind und
jetzt vor einem gericht sind was die
leute nicht kennen das man hat ein
gefühl der fremdheit dann die
entscheidend irgendwo weit weg und das
wurde doch sehr kritisiert dass ein
fernes gericht die dinge entscheidet und
nicht mehr die gerichte in der nähe und
wir haben zum beispiel ein bild auch
vorbereitet wo man sieht dass jedem
wirklich auf ganz höchster ebene mit den
regierungen dann geredet haben ich habe
ja eine fotografie hier wie sie mit frau
merkel unterwegs sind und das kann den
eindruck erwecken die ganz oben die
regierungen und die hohen richter
die richten das halt und es ist nicht
mehr dort wo es sein soll den nah bei
den leuten die entscheidung
es handelt sich um einen besuch der
bundeskanzlerin die sie dann an gewicht
so vorgemacht hat nicht das ist also
kein treffen gewesen und kein kein
geheimes treffen sondern wir haben
natürlich auch sehr oft besuch von den
staatschefs der mitgliedsstaaten
wir freuen uns über diesen besuch aber
wir führen hier keine verhandlungen mit
denen nicht also aber man sagt sie
hätten schon auch mal mit dem deutschen
justizministers sondiert wie die
reagieren würden
das ist eine verleumdung das ist nicht
das ist eine verleitung die kamen aus
einem bestimmten quelle und das will ich
das überhaupt nicht kommentieren wer
mich kennt weiß dass ich mit niemandem
nicht nur nicht verhandelt habe sondern
ich kann ihnen versichern dass wir meine
zwölfjährigen zeit als präsident
ich nicht einmal ein anruf erhalten habe
in der analyse in dieser in dieser
richtung also nicht nur hätte ich nicht
angenommen aber ich habe nicht erhalten
da druckversuche gab es nicht in den
sein nein also jeder hat gewusst also
dass das überhaupt keinen sinn gehabt
hätte hätte dann war das eine totale
fehlmeldung die sich hier in aller form
zurück natürlich aber sie wurden zu den
verfechtern der interessen des einzelnen
bürgers und der bürgerinnen auch in
anderen fällen asylgrund homosexualität
als asylgrund frauendiskriminierung
durch versicherungen steht alles haben
wir haben sie in allem war das ist sie
müssen jetzt nur noch an das sind ich
meine ich wollte sagen also vielleicht
noch einen satz dazu ich meine dieses
europa der werte
diese werte sind erwähnt in den
verträgen mehrmals in der präambel zu
dem vertrag über die eu hat in den
artikel 3 also des eu vertrages nicht
okay aber da applaudieren ihnen ja auch
alle die sich noch auf jeden fall
trotzdem bleibt offenbar das gefühl noch
es ist nicht unser europa das ist es das
scheint alles noch so weit weg dieses
luxemburg und dieses brüssel von den
menschen in deutschland und in
frankreich und in osteuropa in südeuropa
ja aber wie kann man dem entgegenkommen
tja meine man kann ja nicht jetzt
regionale gerichte über errichten die
dann eben europäisch genannt werden es
muss eine instanz geben die dann eben
zentral ist wir sind ja nicht in brüssel
sondern werde die luxemburg ich finde
und ich sagte immer die sind sehr gut in
luxemburg aufgehoben weil wir natürlich
auch richten über die kompetenzen der
sehr wichtigen institutionen und dass
wir hatten ja mehr und mehr haben sie
denen ja also das ist natürlich auch ein
punkt nicht denn man sehen muss also man
muss unabhängig sein natürlich auch
gegenüber
institutionen richtig sie zeichnen und
ich denke mit recht ein sympathisches
bild von einem europa das es auch
schafft die grundwerte die die
menschheit sich in den menschenrechten
und so erarbeitet hat durchzusetzen mehr
vermutlich als irgendwo sonst auf der
welt jetzt komme ich aber zu anderen
hypothese dass europa nicht nur die
hochburg der menschenrechte ist sondern
auch die hochburg der macht kolosse
nicht andere machen das auch aber
europas macht kloss und die zitterpartie
um den dreck sind und den austritt ihres
heimatlandes griechenlands aus dem euro
ist jetzt im moment aus den schlagzeilen
wieder raus aber sie hat doch sehr
interessante grundsatzfragen ans licht
befördert und als grieche der als zu
höchstem einfluss in der eu gebracht hat
haben sie eine ganz interessante
scharnier position finde ich ja und als
kirche müssen sie nicht auch sagen als
sie sagt und auf hart ging damals im
sommer hat ist die eurozone nicht
unheimlich brutal umgesprungen mit dem
schwachen kleinen griechenland und er
hat gesagt ihr habt geschummelt wenn er
jetzt nicht spurt steht auf schummeln
der untergang
ja es ist natürlich eine sehr schwierige
frage und ich kann natürlich dazu in dem
sinne auch keine hundertprozentige
stellung nehmen weil nicht
ausgeschlossen ist dass diese fälle dann
auch zum gerichtshof kommen
was ich damit sagen will es gibt ja wenn
sie so wollen nachfolge fälle nicht die
sich auch auf individueller basis bilden
beispielsweise also als die geschichten
mit zypern war haben wir fälle also
individuell fälle bekommen vor dem
gerichtshof und auch vor dem gericht
und das könnte auch bei griechenland der
fall ist aber sie sind nicht mehr
richter dort müssen trotzt ich muss
natürlich auch ich muss schweigen und
ich will schweigen weil es natürlich
eine gewisse wie soll man sagen einige
wissen eindruck hat so der macht wenn
selbst der für das gericht so für seine
meinung dazu gibt ihm recht also wir
haben ja natürlich verpflichtungen die
über das eigentliche amt hinaus aber
nicht im juli sei grundsätzlich das
politische das war doch ein ziel das
politische das politische ist natürlich
etwas was einen einem zu denken gibt
ganz allgemein die situation ist
sicherlich eine sehr schwierige
situation in griechenland das ist eine
sehr schwierige situation gewählt
geworden wie man sein dass man sie ums
haar zum ministerpräsidenten
griechenlands gemacht hätte das müssten
andere beantworten ist alleine
bestimmten tag also 2011 das war 2011 im
november 2011 dass ich da und plötzlich
ministerpräsident werden sollte
glücklicherweise für griechenland für
mich wenn ich es nicht geworden und
werden sie gegangen wenn der ruf
gekommen wäre in höchster not
das weiß ich nicht ich meine einfach
wäre es nicht gewesen auf der anderen
seite will ich natürlich nicht
verheimlichen dass wenn jetzt wenn
jemand gebeten wird in einer
notsituation so ein amt zu übernehmen
sehr schwer ist dann letztlich nein zu
sagen aber ich muss betonen vor diese
situation habe ich nicht gestand
es trifft zu dass man mich informiert
hat dass so etwas hätten kommen können
aber das war nur ein paar stunden am
nachmittag kam dann die entwarnung und
die war für mich natürlich ein sehr
versierter eine gute nachricht aus mainz
aber man kann es sich auch vorstellen
sie sind glaube ich ein mensch der macht
an macht interessiert ist in dem sind
gestaltungsmacht sie wollen auf dieser
welt etwas mit gestalten und verändern
das ist schon ein bisschen der
lebensplan klapproth ich will also für
europa arbeiten und wenn du weit ist
soweit meine kräfte noch reichen und für
das was mich interessiert für dieses
europa der werte und für diese
rechtsgemeinschaft und ich sehe also
nicht es als meine aufgabe aber auch
nicht dass meine bestimmung man braucht
mich glaube ich in griechenland nicht so
sehr wie sie glauben
europa hat sie dann und das gericht
gebraucht um zu entscheiden ob diese
historische entscheidung von mario
draghi dem chef der europäischen
zentralbank richtig war zu sagen
whatever it takes wie schwämmen und ein
altes europa mit geld voll bis die
spekulanten gut also billig ist etwas
vereinfacht dargestellt wenn ich war
nicht das war interessant das gericht
musste dann entscheiden hat die ezb das
recht gehabt ja oder nein und das
gericht hat gesagt ja und karlsruhe das
bundesverfassungsgericht in deutschland
sei aber skeptisch
das sind wieder momente schon
interessant wo wo höchste gerichte nicht
einer meinung sind und waren sie dann
einfach höher und gilt das was luxemburg
sa man muss natürlich hier
differenzieren
es ist ja das bundesverfassungsgericht
dass sich an uns gewandt hat und die
frage gestellt hat ob und inwiefern
dieses system mit den verträgen
vereinbar das ist das system was die
geldflut unerlaubt ja also die die den
ankauf von anleihen am sekundärmarkt
man muss sie zu sagen also dieses system
hat niemals funktionieren und ist auch
die hand gereicht um die spekulanten zur
ankündigung eine könnte ja weil die
ankündigung hat gereicht um das dann in
das ist natürlich auch ein punkt wer
faktisch rechtlich ist das irrelevant
aber faktisch sollte man das buch zur
kenntnis nehmen also das
bundesverfassungsgericht zum ersten mal
an uns gewandt mit der frage ob und
inwiefern das mit dem vertrag vereinbar
ist was die ezb gemacht hat und hat zu
verstehen gegeben dass seiner meinung
nach bedenken bestehe auch im hinblick
auf das europäische recht was das
bundesverfassungsgericht jetzt wird
unsere antwort macht ist seine sache was
wir gesagt haben ist dass dieses system
sowie es entwickelt worden ist
mit dem vertrag und mit den kompetenzen
der ezb und mit dem primär recht
vereinbar war aber unter bestimmten
bedingungen das heißt also es ist keine
card plage sondern es ist ein system das
auch rechtlich gebunden ist und dass
dann auch gerichtlich kontrolliert wird
aber ohne zu sehr eben in die details
gehen die man hier noch in der schweiz
noch weniger kennt als in der eu wo das
auch ein fall ist er einen direkt
betrifft es ist ja doch schon so dass
gerade aus deutschland
karlsruhe und frühere richter roman
herzog der dann auch bundespräsident
ich habe ganz haarige dinge zum teil
gesagt über das gericht margret thatcher
hatte er ausgesagt dieses gerecht heißt
alle macht an sich und verändert aber
wir haben überlebt er knapp sie sehen
doch da und das stimmt aber klar ist es
schon war das bitter wenn man sagt die
die die ist ihnen das egal
nein egal ist das natürlich nicht man
ist doch betroffen
das ist ganz klar aber wissen sie ich
meine man muss sehen und man muss die
dinge so betrachten wie sie dann
wirklich sehr
und wir sind nicht in einer konkurrenz
mit den nationalen gerichten wir
befinden uns nicht in der konkurrenz
fand ich sowieso und auch nicht in eine
hierarchie
das war nicht eben faszinierend als ich
mich da ein gelesen habe ich habe
gedacht mal sagen ich bin das höchste
gericht gemacht was ich sage nein sie
sind dauernd am reden dass ein palaver
im besten sinne einfach andere
überzeugen das ist wenn wir nicht
überzeugen können mit unseren
entscheidungen dann werden dann
riskieren wir dass sie nicht befolgt
und bislang ist das eben
glücklicherweise nicht geschehen weil
wir uns genau bemühen auch unsere
kollegin in den mitgliedsstaaten davon
zu überzeugen dass wir in einem wie sie
sagen ich will diesen einen verhandlungs
verhältnis zueinander sind aber wir sind
in einem fell in einem verhältnis der
gegenseitigen kooperation wo die
kompetenzen abgesteckt werden also
wahrheitsfindung die müssen den fall
entscheiden nicht wir
wir geben unsere meinung zu der
interpretation und zu der anwendung des
europarechts das finde ich faszinierend
wahrheitsfindung durch
reden miteinander durch das treffen uns
auch so wieder genauso oft mit
nationalen gerichte gerne auch mit der
schweizerischen so was ihre ich komme
auch darauf was sie denn gesagt was die
ihnen gesagt haben aber ich stelle also
fest mich bilanziere ein bisschen europa
als hort der menschenrechte haben sie
dargestellt wie ich finde überzeugend
europa als macht moloch haben sie
abgewehrt das können sie keine nennen
finde ich auch kann man so sehen jetzt
gibt es noch eine bösartige these für
siege hab ich europa als missgeburt es
gibt leute die sagen es ist ein totales
veh konstrukt von beginn weg wenn man
verschiedene kulturen verschiedenen
nationen mit anderen lebensprinzipien
unter 1 norman dach stellen will und das
thema birgt die gefahr dass wir hier so
schlimm und schrecklich in die klischees
abstürzen ich glaube mit einem mann wie
ihn da so viel erreicht hatte in europa
und das griechenland kommt kann man das
sagen und ich würde mal sagen das geht
nämlich dass die welt von griechenland
bekommen hat ist zum beispiel das bild
aus dem berühmten film alexis sorbas er
nach dem roman von nikos kazantzakis wo
man eindrücklich sieht die begegnung
eines lebenslustigen alten griechen
alexis sorbas eben mit einem
kontrollierten jungen engländer der
heißt asyl im film und der höhepunkt des
films ist ja jetzt wie das kohlebergwerk
einstürzt dass der junge engländer
geerbt hat und dass ein griechischer
vertrauensmann er so was eben hätte auf
vordermann bringen sollen und das hat
mich gut geklappt ja nicht sauber
gearbeitet und am schluss als alles
schon stand
das unter großem getöse zusammen und man
würde sagen da bleibt gar nichts übrig
und das schon als kind hatte ich den
film gesehen und fand das faszinierend
vor allem wie die beiden reagieren
nachdem alles zusammengebrochen ist der
engländer der schockiert ist und der
grieche und wie reagieren sie
sie tanzen sirtaki
das wollen wir uns auch anschauen wie
dieser tage tanzen was hast du jemals
erlebt dass etwas so viel zusammen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist eine ur schiffer die wir hier
haben von griechenland vassilios skouris
ist das so die welt kam zusammen bereich
in griechenland kann zusammenbrechen
der grieche tanzt weiter ich würde zwei
lehren aus dieser szene ziehen zunächst
einmal und ich glaube das ist auch so
gemeint vom kazantzakis dieses land ist
ja oft in schwierigkeiten gewesen in
große schwierigkeiten geraten und es hat
es geschafft dann doch immer wieder auf
so auf zu aufzuerstehen und das ist
natürlich etwas was man vielleicht auch
auf die heutige situation übertragen
kann
hoffe ich dass man dann eben auch fehler
gemacht hat in der vergangenheit und
dass es doch häufig gelingen wird jetzt
wieder dieses den impetus zu finden und
zu dass dieses land noch einmal
aufgeblüht der zweite kommen da wäre
also es ist für mich natürlich eine
hoffnung dass ich nicht den gerichtshof
so verlassen haben
er steht noch einmal wenn ich heute
morgen gebäude zusammengebrochen essen
als es ist und zur these dass eben die
nordeuropäer und die südeuropäer nicht
zusammenpassen ich meine 50 jahre nach
dem film besteht diese these in der
spätester weise weiter in diesem sommer
hat der spiegel ein titelbild zeichnen
lassen von seinem karikaturisten samson
der sehr begabt ist wie wir sehen aber
auch ziemlich frech tanzt ein besorgter
deutscher mit dem geld in der hand mit
einem lebenslustigen griechen dem ist
schnurzpiepegal ist hat ja auch um so in
der hand dass man an dass sie alle in
der eu am abgrund sind das ist schon das
bild das viele haben in der eu der
fleißigen orten und der lebenslustige
frau die süden die passen nicht zusammen
was sagen sie als einer der beides in
sich tragen
ja ich glaube nicht dass dieses bild
korrekt ist zunächst einmal ist nicht
korrekt dass der süden faul ist also das
würde ich nicht akzeptieren
man kann mit statistiken wie sie wissen
vieles machen in die andere in die eine
oder andere richtung ich kann sagen aus
so aus auch aus meinen aber dass er ist
nicht so genau nimmt mit den normen ich
meine es gerade von inseln ich weiß
nicht was abging post plötzlich ist 20
prozent der bevölkerung offiziell blind
weil seine rente ging es war leider
etwas mehr sogar mehr nein das will ich
auch gar nicht gar nicht verkennen
beziehungsweise nicht zur kenntnis
nehmen also griechenland hat sehr viele
fehler gemacht in der vergangenheit das
steht fest
aber es ist nicht richtig zu glauben
dass die menschen in irgendeiner form
faul sind ich würde eher sagen
diejenigen die das glück haben heute
arbeit zu haben noch die sind besonders
fleißig weil sie natürlich wissen also
die müssen auch sehr fleißig sein also
dieses bild ist nicht besonders gut und
es trifft auch nicht zu in diesem sinne
jedenfalls meine persönlichen
erfahrungen mit dem norden sind nicht
diejenigen die dann eben dieses gefälle
tatsächlich bestätigen würden dass ist
das ist auf menschlicher ebene aber auch
auf institutioneller ebene nicht der
fall wenn wir jetzt vom kleinen
griechischen von kleinen europäischen
land kriechen dann zu einer anderen
kleinen europäischen land kommen und zur
schweiz in der fläche noch dreimal
kleiner bissen weniger einwohner aber
sonst nicht ganz unvergleichbare von den
dimensionen her
wenn der kellner sie nachher im
restaurant wo wir sitzen erkennen würde
würde er ihnen vielleicht hier in der
schweiz in ihnen einen fremden richter
sehen
das haben die leute nicht gerne hier
fremde richter
ich will so fragen mit den letzten fünf
minuten die wir hier in diesem gespräch
haben würden sie wenn sie in unseren
schulen ständen sich anschließen wollen
als kleines land dieser riesen
organisation eu wo so viel ist schon
entschieden ist und so viel macht weit
weg ist ich würde zunächst einmal fragen
ist das nicht faktisch so dass die
schweiz großenteils ein europa der
europäischen union gebunden ist
wirtschaftlich und wirtschaftlich aber
auch institutionell durch die
verpflichtung praktisch dies eins zu
eins zu übernehmen was in europa
entschieden wird schon da sagt die eben
wieder zur stärksten kraft bei den
wahlen gewordene partei die svp hier das
wollen wir eben nicht hier wollen wir
einen riegel schieben keine übernahme
mehr haben sie verständnis ich würde
sagen nein weil ich für mich die schweiz
ein sehr europäisches land ist und ich
möchte also nicht wissen dass die
schweiz also ihren mehrwert auch dazu
beiträgt dass europa auch besser wird
nicht in jeder beziehung
aber ich möchte vielleicht etwas zum
fremden richter sagen ich kann das
begreifen
von der idee her dass man also dies als
eine als ein problem darstellt aber ich
kann ihnen sagen
dadurch dass die europäische union so
gewachsen ist werden die meisten
entscheidungen mal uns am gerichtshof
von richtern getroffen die für gemessen
an dem fall der der ausgangsfall ist
auch vor dem trichter sind es ist auch
ein irrglaube zu meinen dass der richter
der aus dem land kommt aus dem der fall
stammt an diesem fall arbeitet nein da
tritt man in den austern nein auch nicht
aber es ist es besteht erstens überhaupt
keine garantie der wird nie
berichterstatter das ist klar
also das ist eine goldene regel kein
präsident gibt einen fall
nicht aus dem land stammt dem richter
der auch aus dem land stammt das steht
fest ob er jetzt an diesem fall mitwirkt
ist eine frage der konstellation also
viele fälle viele fälle
ich würde sagen sogar die meisten fälle
werden von fremden richtern in diesem
sinne entschieden
also insofern sollte man das glaube ich
etwas genauer betrachten
ich kann verstehen dass dann das ein
problem ist aber ich glaube nicht dass
das ein unüberwindliches problem sein
würde das argument ist die sind ebenso
fremd gegenüber dem eu bürger
die sind nicht voreingenommen mehr
gegenüber der schweiz werden das ja
nicht lösen können gab interessante
fernduelle zwischen dem bei den
außenminister burg alter und ihnen er
sagte er wollte sie als gutachter dass
gerichte und das wollen sie aber nicht
nur gutachter seien
das können wir hier und müssen sie auch
nicht ausdiskutieren sondern ganz zum
schluss möchte ich zurückkommen zur
person dieses griechischen juristen der
renolit in europa erreicht hat in
luxemburg beim höchsten gericht der
wichtigste mann war jetzt zwölf jahre
lang was bleibt hängen an gutem vielen
gibt es dinge die ihnen manchmal noch
schlaflose nächte bereiten gibt es fälle
wo sie sagen
dort hatte ich mich geehrt wissen sie
das kann man in so einem gericht das
kollegiale entscheidungen trifft
glücklicherweise nicht als gefühl haben
dass sie waren doch der wettermacher
jetzt sagen sie die wahrheit und nicht
aus
nein nein das ist das ist übertrieben
sicherlich hat der präsident eine
wichtige funktion aber kann doch nicht
eine entscheidung vor bestimmen
und er kann doch nicht gegenüber seinen
kollegen ich meine wir haben zu 15
entschieden ja ja dann das budget sie
stehen nicht alleine aber haben sie
vielleicht mal falsch
bringt man mit sich ich suche kann
folgendes sicherlich sagen ich bin ja
nicht immer einverstanden gewesen mit
der mehrheit das ist ja normal nicht und
ich glaube also dass ich recht hatte
nicht einverstanden zu sein aber dass
das mehr schlaflose nächte bereitet kann
ich nicht behaupten weil ich auch das
system verteidigen muss und verteidigen
will
das eben die mehrheit recht hat und
nicht also auch eine minderheit die
vielleicht nach meinem dafürhalten die
besseren argumente für sich hätte das
ist das system damit muss man sich
abfinden und man muss dieses system auch
verteidigt das motiv war das haben sie
gesagt sie haben nach gerechtigkeit
gesucht wird dieses europa haben sie
sich gefunden
nein das wäre übertrieben zu sagen dass
man sie findet das ist ein ständiger
prozess
man darf nicht die suche auf gebe herr
richter skouris ganz herzlichen dank
dass sie als erstem fernsehsender hier
uns ihre gedanken offen gelegt haben die
gedanken eines mannes der sehr viel
gesehen hat sehr hoch gekommen ist und
was sie jetzt machen nicht abwehren
vermutung
man wird auch in der öffentlichkeit
vielleicht wieder von ihren höhe
hinhören oder war ihrem bäcker oder sie
haben sie vielen dank für die einlage
hat mich sehr gefreut dass ich diese
gelegenheit gehabt haben wir bedanken
uns am nächsten sonntag begrüßt sie hier
dann meine kollegin barbara bleisch und
ich bedanke mich jetzt ganz herzlich für
das zuschauen und wünsche allen einen
schönen sonntag
[Musik]